people and we must do it if we don't
control insiders this will be over and
over to lead and any big fat love find
common ground to the spread of lives and
we must do it big F love common ground
to hold the spread of lives and a
America First America First not fatal
want to build a much better believable
people and we must do it non fatal
communication very much higher America
first to lead fight and any insiders
fighting for insiders time to stop
insiders fighting for insiders more of
insiders fighting for insiders time to
stop insiders fighting for insiders
America First Love the flow
[Music]
iide
down
friends don't
quiet hey we're back to our
regularly nothing here is regularly
scheduled I guess uh our a typically
scheduled uh programming or type of
programming in a second but uh wanted to
let you know that today is uh a
different type of program that we
scheduled because we have here a police
report uh let me ask you this first when
we did the Nashville Manifesto story
when that was
leaked that very episode and piece of
content was struck down from YouTube so
if you are watching right now this is
where we just ask you to share like make
sure that this gets out to whoever may
not be tuning in because uh the
Nashville Manifesto um worked in spite
of big Tech which means we're relying on
you and of course you can head over to
rumble but I wanted to take a moment
here to just
set the stage a little bit to give you
some context what we have today is a
story
regarding a would be school shooting
thank God didn't take place and a police
report um where we know who this person
was going to
Target why and how that may not seem
like news um the scary part is that the
administration kn knew
it the police knew about
it a lot of people knew about it except
for you the
parents you were never
told and this is part of a really
disturbing Trend this is why I'm so
grateful for the great work that uh
people here do with mug Club undercover
none of it happens without your support
um is there's there's there's too much
of
this there's there's not enough of a
focus at this point I I would actually
argue they cease to exist if you put
your children in public school parental
rights we've heard this a lot and it
kind of goes back to Hillary Clinton
where it was turned into um a
catchphrase that it takes a
village takes a village let me ask you
this and this is where we are today and
we'll have all the receipts and the
clips and the references you can check
them out on the website it takes a
village what if the
village is the
problem what if the enemy and I use that
word carefully is actually inside the
village what if the Village is teaching
your children that all of your values
are wrong that everything you want to
instill in your own children is wrong
your values on Freedom Family Faith sex
any of
it it's all counteracted by Village
members Public School teachers faculty
local Representatives public servants
who teach your children when you don't
have them for eight hours a day
sometimes nine sometimes 10 if you put
them in daycare that all of your values
are mere patriarchy
oppression systemic discrimination Faith
Family
Freedom think about is that a village
does it take that Village and this
village and we're seeing this across the
country gets your children so angry so
confused so hopeless and mentally unwell
that they are inspired to act on it
violently The
Village inspires the child to act on it
to kill
your
children we're seeing more and more of
the
village did
that and what about when that happens or
thank God in this case it's thwarted The
Village decides that it's better that
you don't know the village knows you the
parent you're not the village you don't
have a right to know only the village
handles it I want to make something
clear here and this is why I don't find
any virtue in finding common ground
based on a lie these Public School
teachers if they're complicit are not
your village the dean the administrators
are not your village that's not the
village the the police involved if
that's the case and not always they are
not your village and there's a way to
handle something like this I'm not
worried about copycats anymore because I
don't live there uh this happened to me
where someone who was a terrorist
sympathizer posted my address posted the
places that I usually went at this point
in time when I lived in Michigan and a
call to action to commit an act of
violence against me and my family now
someone across the pond in Europe
actually spotted this cross referenced
the doxing information with the local
public police the local police
department they showed up at my house
and said hey we have this tip uh just so
you know we're aware of it uh what
measures are you taking to secure your
house this is what we recommend and you
know what we'll do some drive-bys on
every shift uh as this continues to go
on now see that's a village that's what
to hand it that's not what
happened here today and if you have the
wrong point of view you have the wrong
values that's not what happens you're
not a part of the village and let me
give you some more context here it takes
a Village People Say Yeah historically a
village is more than just some people I
believe the term used to be larger than
a hamlet smaller than a town but for a
fortnite only I
guess the village used to be clustered
around one Central Point yeah a Town
Square more importantly a village was
representative of shared interests and
values people coming together a
community which we talk about so much
hey Community is supposed to matter a
village the villagers were also there to
protect the people of the village a
village needs to share
values if these public
servants the real heroes as are often
called don't share your values no if
they don't
viously
fight for your same
values they have your kids eight hours a
day and they are not your
village and today's story is bone
chilling uh it's important because you
especially if you're from the school
district should have known this in the
first
place but there's a macro that I don't
want to be lost here because this exact
story can apply anywhere across this
country whether it's Lowden County in
Virginia with boys and girls restrooms
and a dad being escorted by police
because he complains about it or people
at a town
hall who don't want a guy wrestling
their young
women it happens across the country on a
regular basis and we need to
differentiate between public servants
and people who are suckling at the
public te who offer no value and even
worse they corrode the fabric of society
and a village and we thank you I can't
thank you enough if you want to support
uh us of course you can go to Lad
credit.com mug Club none of this
investigative journalism mug Club
undercover happens I think we can bring
that up full screen um and you can send
in your tips it doesn't happen because
guess
what the village has decided that they
don't want you and us here as a member
so guess what we're our own
village let's use that term
appropriately all right on with the
[Music]
show
oh I forgot to sip
cold open hey before I get to anything
else uh and today is a little bit
different because we have an exclusive
um some news off the top breaking uh
Nikki Haley has lost the Nevada Primary
this happened yesterday by embarrassing
30 points to the choice uh of none of
these candidates which actually appeared
on the ballot some context that option
appeared above Nikki Haley as a
selection on the ballot followed by
Nikki Haley as the next voting option
followed by if you want to choke a
[Laughter]
all right today we'll be talking
about jeez well not really much Joe
Biden we already just talked about Nikki
Hy I don't have anything else to add to
that and uh mug Club undercover an
exclusive story here today um this
buried Middle School Manifesto the
police report and the administrative
officials who were involved with it so
again thank you very much for your
support and you know share it uh with
anyone out there who can oh I'm hearing
now that Nikki Haley just issued a
statement after her loss I told them
that if they would do this that South
Carolina would wrap their arms around
them and take care of them I now
officially work for you there is nothing
that you can need that we won't make
sure that we deliver sorry right
clip and it's I I told you we're gonna
have that run nonstop every day we fit
it in it's a skill like anything else if
today at any point and I guarantee you
you will see
this that's the YouTube dump you head on
over to rumble it's a live show m Monday
through just say weekdays 10 a.m.
eastern uh let me ask you this question
before we get to it is there ever a
situation that justifies a School hiding
information from parents doesn't have to
involve a wouldbe shooting or pipe
bombs although to be honest you know
look pipe bomb's bad right but I learned
how to make a pin cushion in homech but
I never learned how to do taxes so I'd
like to know how to make a pipe bomb
sure not that I would ever use it yeah
it's a more useful skill than pin
cushions than trigonometry ah I would be
more likely to use a pipe bomb or be
able to make a pipe bomb then use
trigonometry do you need trigonometry to
build a pipe bomb comment below number
two CEO Captain Morgan how are you I am
doing well though I'm a little disturbed
by your desire to be able to make a pip
bom I don't want to I don't want to make
a pipe bomb don't put words in my mouth
I said it was a more useful skill okay
it was a more useful skill than making a
pin cushion that's true if whever breaks
out here you're not going to have pin
cushions and then in third chair today
who was upset that I didn't change his
music yet but we kind of have some other
things going on here uh just for that
May 11 he's going to be
incity no assist his box hey now count
bayy Center Red Bank New Jersey a
fantastic theater and uh he's the OG you
absolutely should go and see him he has
his own show here in mug club uh Monday
through Thursday 5: P p.m. Eastern
funniest man alive Nick Della how are
you sir very good thank you very much I
think uh schools should be able to hide
information from parents especially
around report card time yes well there
are exceptions to every rule was your
dad really strict with report like did
you know if you had bad if you had bad
grades was he going to beat you no he'd
beat me if I had good grades he did he
didn't give a he put my hand in a
panini makeer for three minutes cuz I
got a D on a
map he's sitting at home it was a waffle
iron we didn't have P makers back a
D remember
this all right
W that's it's a serious crime it is and
we're all sick that's wonderful we have
to make something funny today right well
it's it's you know what this is it's it
is laughable but it's not funny uh hey
you know what else hey it's always funny
it's good for a laugh before I move on
uh former Vice President Joe Biden
respect the office was confronted about
the possibility of a Donald Trump debate
and of course his answer well it brings
us to this this weekend Biden if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black Donald Trump ready to debate you
right now do you
St on
radio immediately say immediately will
you why i' want to debate me too if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're from me or Trump and you ain't
black I don't know what that means yeah
but did you see that but this is
something his hand is stapled to that
cup that is not the way a it's it's like
a muppet with a cup where a hand should
be bring bring bring that up go back and
look look at that guys ready to debate
you right it's cup gate oh yeah oh my
God tell everybody let's get his hand
from yeah it's like his cup is like this
it's
like that's not how you hold a cup that
was Gilmore I don't believe he's got
hands like a sloth it was only three
fingers I know right yes he does who
holds a cup like that I don't know
nobody that's who Nick nobody was that
AI nobody I don't know you guys can
comment below but I think cupc is a
thing can we play it one more time
there's something really off butting
about that cup hold look at his off hand
too it looks really
weird Okay so he has so let me make this
clear he has one you know cerebral paly
hand over here and then he has uh this
at the bottom of there's no I can't even
hold this the mug is definitely too
girthy but yeah that's true well you
know what we're a victim of our own
success where's this pinky it doesn't
live doesn't exist I is sticking up
through a hole in the cup you know the
old trick he did the popcorn
thing what are you talking about come on
Father it needs it needs it needs you
got to let it
breathe all right E I would have loved
to seen him try to suck that shake out
of that Str yes oh yeah that would have
been stroke about halfway up give him a
crazy straw you'll kill
him I can get the first one he's the
kind of guy who goes to Dairy Queen they
turn the blizzard upside down he's like
what holy hell yeah I'll never be able
to do that it's magic I'm not gonna lie
I'm still impressed when they do that
that was weird when they turn it upside
down I'm like oh that you did that is
thick
so they still do that they still do
always have that little moment of panic
like what if he's new to this what if
every time my doctor did that at the
sperm
bank
e a
blizard coach tiny
spoon all right oh goodness okay all
right all right so this is the reason
that most of you have tuned in and thank
you again for sharing and get getting
this out there because uh over what do
you think I don't know what over under
means Nick's the one who bets on sports
that this will be struck on YouTube like
the Nashville Manifesto we had we had
several conversations about it yeah
we're still going to cover it YouTube
yeah isn't it and then and then Black
Rock tried to get the other stuff
removed from that still nothing still
nothing hey by the way mayor of
Nashville where's the lawsuit where's
the lawsuit Buttercup I was waiting yeah
we were waiting we were ready all right
so uh here's a story our undercover unit
here um Mud Club for which I'm
internally grateful they have uh come
into some well obtained I want to say
come into because that that would sound
like they just like fell backwards into
it in a drunken stoer they did a lot of
work and they uh they tracked us down
and obtained some exclusive information
including what we have here
and will now be public so you can go
check this out at ler.com uh the
redacted version to protect the innocent
and miners involved uh this story
involves a a buried police report uh and
a Coline style
Manifesto and I'm trying to be very
careful in what I say but the manifesto
specifically also mentions group this is
what's important the students that this
person would be shooter would
Target Christians jocks pretty
girls which may explain to you why the
parents weren't notified it does seem as
though uh safety is based on political
expediency so something else important
the administration knew about it the
Schoolboard knew about it the police
knew about it because there was a police
report only you the parents were not
notified of this serious security threat
where motive at that point was also
something uh for which there was was
information available which would seem
to be relevant in preventing future
crimes this is M Club
undercover so you kind of know what the
story is but uh I think that the
receipts the um the evidence here is is
important so we're making all of that
publicly available uh we're trying to be
as transparent as possible let me play
this for you I will play the full call
later and I'm going to read the police
report in its
entirety lest you say that uh I'm taking
it out of context at the risk of it
being somewhat boring I think you need
to have the full context and then you
can go to the website and check it all
out so this is a brief clip of the full
phone call which we will play later
unedited okay yeah again I'm not trying
to put anybody on the spot or get
anybody in trouble or anything and one
of my friends from the police department
was telling me that there was a
Manifesto found and it was it was pretty
graphic and stuff so it seemed like
something we would normally or you guys
would normally kind of let parents know
about so I just wanted to you know kind
of clarify that or or clear that up
basically Goa yeah yeah Mike can I can I
ask your last name uh honestly I just
want to remain anonymous right now I
don't want any again I'm not trying to
put anybody on the spot or have my kid
you know uh you know shine a light on
him in any way the main thing I was just
trying to find out is basically if you
let parents know and if my wife didn't
tell me you know so okay yeah I just the
reason I asked is just because like I
mean right as as a school district we we
always do everything we possibly can I
mean safety is our number one concern
right there's there's there's never
anything that we do that safety isn't
the Forefront of of what we're doing and
keeping our kids safe keeping our staff
safe everything like that too or
whatever and so um I'm just like just a
little bit curious too that like the the
police department would be would be
leaking something like that to somebody
as well too cuz right like we work
really closely with them and we just
want to make sure that we're you know
we're all on the same page with kind of
you know who's who's saying what to who
and and and that type of stuff all right
so you're just saying the difference is
cops came there was more of a scene so
you want to let people know with this
one there wasn't that same scene so it
just didn't feel necessary to basically
just scare people I guess or alert you
know something like
that
sure okay number one priority is safety
you're doing a hell of a job Corey so
the full call will be uh included here
later in the show it's also important to
note that this doesn't exist in a vacuum
we have Apples to Apples comparisons
where other less credible threats
including a wouldbe school shooting
everyone was notified just not in this
instance why and how many times after a
tragedy have we heard authorities say
you know the the perpetrator was on our
radar yeah and people say well why
didn't you do anything just infuriates
you every time every time this is about
Solutions and sometimes Solutions it's
okay by the way for solutions to to stem
from some seething rage I would be
pretty angry if I were apparent here too
because right now we find ourselves in
this unique position to uh report on
this exact kind of scenario before it
occurs and I want to be really clear
here this is not an attack on the child
in question
uh we will do everything that we can to
help get this child the the help that
they need the source that leaked this to
us was very clear about that as well
this is entirely about a system that has
failed the children I don't even want to
say failed uh our children A system that
breeds discontent and
insecurity and and ill health mentally
that's what this is about and then
people covering up their tracks you've
heard me say this in the past that most
conspiracies don't take place by people
getting together
beforehand plotting it you just can't
get that many people in a room to agree
but you can get a lot of people in a
room after a disaster has occurred to
cover their tracks to save their own ass
that's what we have here and that's what
most conspiracies are to be clear so
last week uh mug Club undercover got an
Insider tip regarding the story in
Chipawa Falls Wisconsin which is exactly
the town name I expect from Wisconsin
it's true fitting the email was titled
school threat tip which by the way again
if you're going to send your tips to lwc
at uh at protonmail.com that's one that
obviously caught our attention as
opposed to like my cat doesn't like my
neighbor's cat we'll get those kinds of
things yes exactly like this is not the
line for that it's a different line call
it cat catcher so according to the
source here there was a student uh at
chipa Falls Middle School who had
written a Manifesto about wanting to
kill students at the school and we
reached out to uh the chipa wa Falls PD
with after this a foyer request for the
material that would you know relate to
that story and this is important because
we talked about this yesterday with the
uh transgender law in Colorado where
felons can change their name and that
would effectively erase their rap sheet
right of course you had people who
supported this law saying well no you
can still search it by a social security
number okay what if you don't have the
social security number no one would know
to make a foyer request for this story
without a tip saying hey there was a
wouldbe school shooting and a Manifesto
that none of the parents know about so
before people on the left try and
counter counteract us say well you got
the information okay someone someone on
a hunch would have to go out and fo
request material relating to a shooting
Manifesto that they didn't know about
think about that now we were denied to
be cleared body uh camera footage
because they said that the name of the
minor in question was frequently used
and that there were excerpts from the
students Manifesto uh that were being
read too frequently so um the whole
thing had to be redacted but we do have
the redacted police report and here's a
small look at what you are about to see
and I'll read the report in its entirety
in a little bit this is part of the
manifesto and by the way there are a lot
of spelling mistakes so it's also a
statement on you know hey we're not
preparing our children to read and write
or do long division yeah but pipe
bombs I know that's not part of the
curriculum but you know I digress uh I
can just
imagine before I move on here and this
is me just being a little a little bit
of a stickler that's not a typo that's
clearly someone who had some options in
head as far as spelling imagine and went
with a m a g n the teacher in question
here should be fired okay I can just
imagine it going into the eighth grade
doors like it's a normal day but then I
pull out a fully loaded semi-automatic
shotgun then as I go through the school
I will throw bombs and tear gas blowing
up the doors of classrooms now here is
something that's also important like
with Nashville the why matters we don't
have all the answers but we have quite a
few I want to kill here's the target
every old man and woman who has claim to
the father Son and Holy Spirit by
chopping their heads off and
putting them on a stick to show there is
no God Only Human Nature I will kill the
most people I can by using explosives
that I will make myself Al he problems
don't even know how to correct that one
that I face will be worth it at after I
kill all the jocks and all those
preppy shitthe headed
girls they need to die and they will go
burn in hell um seems a little
conflicted as far as there is no God but
yeah there's a hell he likes the idea of
hell um we'll go into more details here
um shortly so we have some phone calls
here and Gerald if there's anything that
you think that I'm missing feel free to
step in uh yesterday afternoon so you're
going forward in time and then we'll go
back in time we here Tred to contact
Chipawa Middle School uh their assistant
principal I should say uh Scott Dara to
discuss this story after having done our
due diligence and we were initially
given the
runaround as one I mean look it's also
we're talking about you're talking about
public servants the runaround is
expected but this is how it started CH
Middle School this is Kelly how can I
help you hi I am looking for principal
Daria is he in right now um I don't know
if he's at his desk I can transfer you
is there's something I can help you with
or are you returning a call no uh I'm a
reporter uh working on a story that's
going out tomorrow and it's an urgent
matter to speak with principal Dara it's
regarding a safety incident at the
school um and a police report involving
a student and it's an urgent matter that
I do speak with Mr
Dara and what what repor or where are
you from and what is your name my name
is Lane kindall and I'm a reporter at
louder with Crowder I assure you this is
a call that Mr darche is going to want
to take Lane Kendall louder with what
Crowder
okay if you can hold on for a second
I'll see if he's available thank you
thank you unfortunately he is not
available it doesn't sound like oh hold
on just a second he um can I transfer
you his voicemail no I'm afraid that's
not really going to work cuz we're
working on a time crunch here um I will
be around some of the afternoon though
so is there a good time that I can reach
out and call him today it's very very
time sensitive well you can try and call
back if you want um I'm not you know I
can't guarantee that he'd be available
depending on what the Day brings um but
definitely either I can transer you his
advice now you can leave a a message and
that way when he is available he can
return your call um is there no uh
chance that I might get his cell phone
to try to contact him there again I
really want to I would like to give him
a chance to speak before the story goes
out and it will be going out in the
morning so this is time very time
sensitive okay let me um do you mind if
I put you on hold again see do your
thing I appreciate it
y uh okay uh Mr Kendall yes ma'am okay
can I get a phone number and then I can
have someone from our human resources
department give you a call back so um so
what I can do is I will send an email to
over to you with my number included and
it's going to include a series of
questions that we would really like Mr
Dara to address um I will send it to
both his email and the school General
email and there will be my information
included so feel free free to contact me
at that number okay sounds great thank
you m thank you
bye thank you stonewal
so here's something I want you to keep
in mind we have an entire investigative
team here uh imagine you the parent
trying to get this information right
there it's done you're not going to get
a hold of anybody there's never going to
be any accountability it's the same
thing you know we discussed this with
Carrie Lake when she recorded someone
trying to effectively bribe her right
yeah the attack then became how could
you record somebody well hold a second
if this person is doing something
dishonest if there are actual victims
because of the the crimes or misdeeds
that you perpetrate think about that for
a second imagine you are not an
investigative journalism unit but a
parent you're not going to get a call
back luckily we were able to also I want
to be really clear after this call we'll
show you the damage control only because
of this digging did they come out with a
statement and they'll try to say well we
address it well you addressed it months
later after you got a call from our guy
so we were finally able to reach Daria
oh but that's because people here are
good at their job on his cell
phone hello Scot Dasa hi Mr Dasa sorry
we just got cut off that last time my
name is Lane Kindle and I'm a reporter
uh at louth Crowder I just spoke with
your secretary and unfortunately we
weren't able to get a hold of you
through the school so we wanted to uh
concerning an urgent matter we reached
out to your cell phone I hope that's
okay but um I just have a couple
questions for you um we're actually
getting ready to run a story tomorrow
regarding your school and regarding the
events that took place on October 23rd
2023 concerning a middle school student
and the alert system Aristotle that was
triggered through your school um and the
resulting events around that and I just
wanted to reach out to you before we did
that story and see if you had any
comment or any anything that you wanted
to let us know about
that no I'm curious why you guys are
running a story on that well because we
have actually had um information given
to us through a source in chipal Falls
concerning the matter and after hearing
that tip we actually
contacted um appropriate sources and
have received a police report so we are
very familiar with the incident in a
detailed Manner and we believe that it
is a story that people should know and
we are curious as to why people in the
community were not made aware of such
serious issues involving your
school hi this is DK CL I'm actually the
principal of the school I'm here with Mr
DHA as well um we typically if we're
going to respond to something like this
we typically have a written response
that we would share with you um is there
an email or something that we could um
share with you or that you could send me
an email regarding what you're looking
for and that way we could have a WR
response yeah absolutely we'll have an
email going out here in just a few
moments actually regarding all the
questions that we would like to address
but while we have you on the phone are
you sure there's nothing you'd like to
comment on because this um we are going
to be putting this out first thing in
the morning and we just want to make
sure that we're getting the full the
full story before we do yeah I'm not
going to comment right now without
seeing everything and having a couple
minutes to process it okay well in that
case we'll have that email we'll have
that email to you uh within the next few
minutes or uh within the next half hour
and I just want to confirm your email so
we're getting that to the right
place my email
is Chip CIP P Falls F lls.org
okay let me read that back to
you yep at chip
falls.org correct okay well you can
expect that email shortly and we look
forward to your response thank you thank
you and at best very unprofessional for
a principal to have such a profane email
I can't believe it
wow um horrible so that happened and
then and we'll get to the police report
here but there was damage control right
after after complete silence for a very
long period of time no parents could
have possibly known about this uh for
months they received our email and then
the superintendent Jeff Holmes and uh
the principal I guess there Derek kman
sorry
the D is the assistant princip the
assistant principal aaty for the higher
ups here you go okay so the real
principal Derek kman they put out a
press release last night 8:08 p.m. and
it said a few concerned community
members have contacted our district
about a situation that occurred several
months ago involving one of our students
at the middle school how much you want
to bet there were no few concerned
community members because they couldn't
have known about the incident we have
also been contacted by two online media
Outlets about the student both us at no
time were any of our students at risk or
In Harm's Way thanks to our Middle
School staff's dedicated efforts oh
they're so thank you for the
dedication go back to that call in case
you forgotten remember Dara said I'm
curious why you guys are running a story
on that I'm curious why community
members would reach out according to
your press release you're curious I'm I
guess all curious It's like Spider-Man
with the the meme with the point of
curious curious curious curious oh
that's right you're full of crap yeah
exactly I his comment right there if you
go back up to it really quickly his
comment that at no time were any
students risk or In Harm's Way when we
read this police report to you yes that
will become very very clear that he is
lying yes because they took action and
we'll get to that but this police report
does send a chill up your spying going
oh my gosh yeah they were in danger for
sure yes without a doubt and this is
something to we talk about again the
village hey isn't it their job to keep
your children safe I know people talk
about hey I'm a public school teacher
you have no idea how hard it is I have
to buy school supplies okay it's your
job to ensure that students are
safe kind of first and foremost that's
part of our Unwritten or actually
written agreement with public
establishments that our children attend
we assume that they're not going to be
targeted and victimized before we get to
critical race Theory so let me read you
this and this will be available like I
said in its entirety minutes read it'll
take about 5 minutes but it's important
it's important I apologize uh for having
to read all of it but we know their
playbook before they play it dear Kevin
Yes dear guy with a colorful tie what is
with the outfits oh my God douch so uh
this is this is the police report on
October 23rd 23 at approximately 12:30
hours I officer Downey of the chipa
Falls Police Department was informed by
Dean Han of several Aristotle alerts
that were created by 13-year-old name
redacted because they're underage and
Aristotle alert is a program that
notifies School administration of
certain words that are typed into school
Chromebooks these range from a variety
of racial slurs to the words bomb
shooting Etc by the way if you're out
there and you work uh with
Aristotle send your tips to lwc uh lwc
tips lwc tips protonmail.com I'm curious
as to what these trigger words and
racial slurs are that's an aside but it'
be interesting yeah very interesting the
user in all of these Aristotle alerts
are redacted this is confirmed to be
redacted username there is a URL
attached to all the Aristotle alerts
pictures were taken of the Aristotle
alerts of the URL links and they've been
attached to the
case the first Aristotle alert was
completed on October 22nd at
approximately 13057 a.m. in the title it
was labeled as complete store story of
Coline shooting YouTube when clicking on
URL it brings you to several videos of
Columbine shooting the next notification
came in approximately 10 minutes later
at 1:40 in the morning these two
searches were titled how to make a pipe
bomb and nail bomb the first URL was a
Wikipedia search of the Centennial
Olympic Park bombing and the second URL
was a detailed Wikipedia page on how to
make a nail bomb the next alert contains
seven different websites that triggered
the Aristotle Alert in the first URL it
talks about how to make a pipe bomb and
has videos on how to do so the second
URL shows a subject putting little beads
of some material into a plastic bottle
which then explodes after several
seconds a video of this was taken and
included in the report the third URL
notification was titled how to make a
pipe bomb this video goes step by step
on how to make a cookie recipe followed
by the song lyrics Never Going To Give
You Up he got Rick Rolled he did get
Rick
Rolled he likes to have a laugh pipe
bomb pipe bomb Rick Roll I can
appreciate that the fourth URL was
titled improvised thermite grenade this
goes into details on how to build a
thermite grenade the fifth notification
was him looking back at the second URL
video the six URL is titled legal bombs
and how to make explosives and not go to
prison you know it requires a little
more digging than that that doesn't just
guarantee that you don't go to prison by
the way this was more of an
informational video the last
notification in this set was titled how
to make a homemade bomb for under
$1 that's if you're going to make a bomb
that sounds sounds like a bargain cheap
under a dollar this is a video of a
person who is using popsicle sticks to
make a Contraption and then they explode
the contraption when a person throws the
Contra okay the next alert contains six
different URLs that range from 149 to
152 the first video shows a video of an
80 g flash powder filed pipe bomb
exploding in the roadway the second
notification again shows a popsicle
stick video fourth video is a website to
two of the videos that he had already
watched of how to make a pipe bomb and
the one including the plastic bottle
exploding the fifth alert was a video
titled teen charge with making soda
bottle bombs the last notification was
titled how to make a pipe bomb which is
a spoof video of a person making a
sandwich of some sort they have to
include this in their report but the
point is there's a lot of retrieving and
then returning to these URLs seems to be
a common threat This Is How They have to
set up the report I'm reading this for
you so that full cont you do not believe
the left or the attackers when they say
they're taking this out of context
that's what they try to do with
Nashville no no no no no no you're
move the last Aristotle alert contained
four different URLs the first one was
titled how to make a new nuclear reactor
at home the second URL is a YouTube
short of a homemade bomb in this it
looks as if there's a large caliber siiz
bullet taped to something with the wick
coming out of it the third URL was
another screenshot of how to make pipe
bombs this would be the third time he
reviewed this page and the fourth URL
notification is a repeat of the second
notification after looking at some of
the Aristotle alerts uh dean of students
Corey Han and I had redacted respond
down to Dean Han's office to speak to
him about the Aristotle alerts a short
time later redacted arrived and sat
we'll just say the shooter or the
wouldbe criminal uh arrived and sat down
in his office I explained to
redacted that at any point in time he
was free to leave the room he could
refuse to answer any questions that I
asked and that we had the door shut for
his privacy he did not have any
questions to any of those statements I
also asked if he was okay that I was in
the room he replied that he was I
explained that we had received Aristotle
alerts and we wished to gain his
perspective on these Aristotle alerts he
replied by stating something to the
effect that he was reading a book and he
was looking to fact check the book
he informed us the book was called the
Anarchist Cookbook I asked if he
happened to have a copy of the Anarchist
Cookbook on his person he stated that he
did not have a physical copy of it
however he had a digital copy on his
Chromebook I also wonder how was that
missed if you saw all these URLs yeah
but the Anarchist Cookbook flew under
the radar yeah he he she Z redacted
opened up the Chromebook and proceeded
to search for the Anarchist Cookbook
provided it to me a quick search as to
what the Anarchist Cookbook is shouldn't
you know that yeah show that this was a
book containing instructions to
manufacture explosives as well as
talking about the home manufacturing of
illicit drugs including LSD furthermore
it shows that this book had been banned
in several several different areas we
know as it's been linked to school
shootings in Colorado and Santa Monica I
looked through the web version and this
information was confirmed to the table
contant okay I asked forwarded to
describe the book to me he went into
stating the first section was about
synthesizing creating drugs related to
methamphetamines hallucinogens and crack
cocaine
then goes on to explain the second
action sorry second section was about
technological tampering the third
section go third section goes into
talking about hand-to-hand combat
weapons including guns knives and
explosives I asked this person why they
liked to read into this type of thing
they stated I don't know I like to read
crazy books so then went on to explain
how they read The Communist
Manifesto and also has this book titled
120 days of Sodom in his uh book list of
book listed to purchase I asked if his
parents knew that he had they had these
books and by the way the police report
just says he repeatedly just one of
those things they stated that they uh
they stated they do not I asked what
they thought they might say when they
found out they were reading that the
reply was don't do any of the things
that are in it they then went on to
explain that they wouldn't do any of
those things in it and that they were
just an idealistic person explain that
this book also gets you a list uh on a
list of some sort and they believed it
was funny to be on on this list they
went on to explain one of the reasons
they bought the book the reason was
self-defense they then stated I don't
know the book isn't really about
self-defense another thing they stated
was that they like to look into these
types of books as part of a party
gag when looking at the online version
of the Anarchist Cookbook I found a
portion that referred to making a tear
gas bomb they stated that was actually
pretty difficult to make went on to
state that they found another item that
was pretty cool to make which would be a
smoke bomb they said a smoke bomb would
act kind of like a flare while emitting
a lot of hot smoke Han advised that we
were going to search this person's
backpack in
person so I say this is important
because
there's reasonable uh suspicion right
there's cause for for suspicion at this
point and now again keep in mind no one
was ever in danger at any point I would
say that this would maybe suffice
because there have been people who have
been expelled suspended for far less
than this and parents would typically be
notified including by the way for Less
credible threats at this
school search the backpack and this
person I proceeded to search their
backpack and did not locate of anything
of evidentiary value in the backpack
while I was searching the backpack Mr
Han continued to talk with redacted
during this I overheard them talk about
they had met blank who was
killed he said that he went down uh
mental spiral after learning of the
death of red acted redacted continued
stating that he was talking with a
counselor about their depression we
asked about their school life they
stated that they think about getting to
lunch when they first arrive at school
and then after lunch they think about
going home this person uh continued
stating that they hate being at school
and the kids are awful and they are
bullies it's about to get worse it gets
a lot worse it's always that thread
though that Common Thread throw the
up anyways go ahead
yeah it gets a lot worse so stated that
he would like to see The Notebook that
was checkered blue black and gold which
was currently sitting on the uh on
hans's desk person stated that they
could not search through that notebook
they stated that it was more of a
religious thing and talked about their
family Han later informed me when he
went to retrieve blank from the
classroom that blank placed everything
in their backpack minus the checkered
notebook this endered the interview of
red ended the interview yeah
the end of the initial interview I spoke
with Han and principal Dara about the
notebook in my office I explained they
had more than enough Reasonable
Suspicion based on the Aristotle alerts
and the interview with this person to
seize the book and read the contents at
about this time I had to leave for a
court appearance while at the court
appearance Han and principal roua gained
access to the checkered notebook they
informed me it was something
serious recall no one was ever at risk
they informed me it was something
serious
few hours later I returned back to
school and reviewed the book I opened
the checkered blue black and gold
notebook and found that it was titled
operator manual to manic
violence the first couple lines of this
Manifesto police reports words State the
first step to my plan is looking online
to purchase PVC pipe and multiple PVC
pipe caps as well as black powder or
gunpowder duct tape steel wool and a
couple of 9volt batteries they continue
to to write about how to make a pipe
bomb they also state that they might
pull nails or bbb's in the gunpowder to
create a shrapnel effect they also talk
about the cost of $70 for this
particular
explosive this person continues on with
a new paragraph titled thoughts it
explains how they hate girls who
objectify themselves redacted writes
about how they are taking inspiration
from the Coline
shooting before it move on we have okay
all of these alerts we have an interview
that is alarming lies about the
interview saying that Checker book is
just about religious stuff don't talk to
my parents they get it and now you have
manuals that reference what was being
searched on school Chromebooks and it
continues you think think the parents
need to know
yet no one was ever at
risk this person continues on the next
page explaining how they thought about
using pressure based explosives daating
they had done research on baking soda
and vinegar they then changed their mind
set from explosives to using Firearms
they state that they know how to obtain
a 22 lever action and a Glock 10 from
their grandfather's house and this
person goes into detail on how to start
the massacre they wrote I would start my
massacre in the morning at 8:20 when
everyone is going inside bring up
reference the Anarchist Cookbook for the
first time writing I will buy said book
and inform you of any change in my plan
they continue into a new thoughts
paragraph about the extermination of
society talks about how the only
solution is death at the bottom of the
page they write I think that all
preparation will be done towards the end
of the school year we now have a time
frame they write about a reset button
for the world and that this person
believes they will be a force that stops
the world the next set of paragraphs was
titled work they state that they have
now found a free to read version of the
Anarchist Cookbook on online and write I
plan to use this to kill multiple
students at my school this will be the
next
Coline I will kill the most people I can
by using explosives that I will make
myself all the problems that I face will
be worth it after I kill all the
jocks and all those preppy
shitthe headed girls who need to
die and they will go burn in hell and I
will be unknown word and that is when I
will kill myself and I will go to the
void because that's what I believe
making this available Link in the video
description on the next page it
continues referencing the Anarchist
Cookbook which was just fun for party
gags let me just pause here for a second
it's not that what we're reading is
disturbing it's that the people in
charge the people who are paid by your
tax dollars to protect you and your
children knew better and lied to you
anyway
that's the
issue this may be a disturbed
kid definitely is a disturbed kid this
may be a disturbed kid who may not act
on it but you have multiple series of
Lies saying no no no I wasn't doing that
no no that was just for a gag and now
you have a document a manuscript that
expresses why they have these materials
why they are searching these materials
confirms that they are now learning how
to use the materials to create weapons
and a plan to use those weapons to
commit as much violence as possible
against their fellow students and a
timeline
yeah but no one's at risk according to
those sorry public
servants on the next page it continues
referencing the Anarchist Cookbook
there's a through line in this section
it appears blank as thinking about how
this book might make him her Z change
their plans they write I from this book
will learn how to make deadly and lethal
weapons create make drugs and tamper and
news Electronics I am glad that I'm
reading it it will help my plan A lot it
continues stating their favorite weapon
style is so far
Napal they go on to talk about how you
can get a 5 gallon bucket with some
gasoline and then put Styrofoam in it
until the styrofoam dis dissolves
leaving them with a sticky
[Music]
putty
also speak about Charles Manson happy
and loves Charles's
ideology along with KL Marx apparently
they continue on the next page talking
about how they hate Christians and want
to end it all they talk about
the indoctrination of children in
reference to
Christianity if this was talking about
gender ideology
or this was talking about progressivism
think the parents would know do you
think you'd hear about the wouldbe white
supremacist shooter
Islam do you think you would
know did you know about
Nashville not even the parents knew
about this so I guess we have another
right-wing extremist right-wing
Christian militia
extremist talking about how they hate
Christians want to end it all and the
indoctrination of children in reference
to Christianity they State I want to
kill every old man and woman who has
claim to the father son Holy Spirit
chopping their heads off and
putting them on a stick just to show
there is no God Only Human Nature it
then continues talking about how they
need a woman to assist them because just
because you have a nice face and a set
of boobs doesn't mean you are above
everyone else the next page they talk
about how they plan on targeting the
jocks and explain why they would Target
the jocks continue saying I will when I
am 18 take a drive to the store and buy
a 20 gauge shotgun and drive up to the
Canadian wilderness and off myself but I
think that I will follow through with
the massacre talks about purching uh
purchasing a trench coat black combat
boots cargo pants and a black shirt with
the word wrath inscribed on it with red
letters where oh that's right
Coline they State sorry they continue
stating that they are going to try and
murder as many people as they can by
shooting them as they make their way
into the school they reference Coline by
stating that they're looking for their
Dylan to their Eric mentions a bomb by
the propane in the lunch line but States
it's much harder because of the
surveillance equipment this is a
detailed plan this is someone who has
thought it out and they're looking for
an accomplice they're looking for an
accomplice somebody to help them carry
this plan out I mean every step along
the way this person sounds very serious
about actually doing what they are
saying hey how could you figure out if
someone is along the path to being an
accomplice if you don't tell anybody
yeah no no other parents knew to look
for the signs in their child to see if
maybe they had been approached they had
no idea still don't till
today the next page they talk about
creating chaos by placing explosives and
blowing up cars in the parking lot or
using the cover of smoke to shoot all
the students next thing they state is I
could do sorry I could on November 30th
crossed out October 30th release a bunch
of the mega smoke bombs in town in
reference from the devil's night and the
unable to read the writing it continues
down the page talking about how they
would obtain a 12 gauge semi-automatic
shotgun and that this would be the gun
of choice they continue on the next page
about changing up the time of the
massacre
specificity no
threat according to the
administration no threat you have no
right to know we now have a time change
we now a squeeze it in on another
date they State they might try and go to
the boy bathroom and start it during the
start of the third hours or the start of
the eighth hour to avoid classes this is
because boys try to avoid them in those
classes on the next page this person
talks about they are searching for the
Dylan to their Eric and again who they
are targeting wait wait wait who they
are
targeting potentially a list of people
that they think is that am I reading
that correctly a list maybe that they're
thinking could be their accomplice
Beyond Christian
jocks yeah not not targeting to kill but
targeting to enlist their services in
this mhm that's the first time that that
stuck out to me so I could be wrong if
I'm wrong and they're not referring to
that if they're referring targeting as
who they're trying to kill which we've
gotten a list of already wait mean I
have the full list in this context it
seems like it's saying targeting like
here are the people that I think might
help me in my plan I just don't like the
fact that they gloss over a
list whether it's another list of
targets or a list
of people who they think would be good
candidates to be the Dy to their Eric
and especially if they had a list of
people who would potentially be another
candidate to join them in this and
didn't notify anybody
else goes on this person is also
thinking about changing tactics to start
shooting inside a bathroom instead of at
the beginning of the school day the next
page refers to killing people and being
upset with certain people groups in the
school they give certain people
groups hey I think you parents you
should you should be to know if it's a
threat or
not certain people groups well that
changes that we have time frames
multiple time frames maybe they're
indecisive we already know Christians
jocks pretty girls so this person was
inspired by liked Charles Manson liked
Carl Marx Anarchist
Cookbook gloss over that we can't know
this is from the foyer request that you
the parents would have never known to
make seem like no one's ever in
danger the next page they State I
hate the people who who know
they were threatened and are in the face
of imminent danger and do nothing AKA
everyone at my school except the
following resource officer that
shows the wrong job he should have
something something the Army and got
shipped overseas so he wouldn't see all
the things I am going to do to the
precious students that he tries to
defend he continues talking about the
semi-automatic TW uh semi-automatic 20
gauge shotgun and Glock 10 that they
plan on using they also referenc to get
a uh an M1 carbine Universal enforcer
automatic assault
rifle and site its
$2,700 which may be a
problem this person was more thwarted by
a price tag than those in
charge on the second to last page they
State I need a physical copy of the
Anarchist Cookbook I mean I'm just
screaming through the online one
skimming I think they meant through the
online one is making me shake with
anticipation and having the real
deal is I think they meant to say more
exciting they referenc using mustard gas
on students between the last two pages
they write I can just imagine it going
into the eighth grade doors like it's a
normal day but then I pull out a fully
loaded semi-automatic shotgun as I go
through the school I will throw bombs
and tear gas blowing up the doors of
classrooms before entering and sending a
a storm SL swarm of slugs flying toward
the group of students huddled up in some
Corner away from the door like a bunch
of on the last page they
state that they plan to warn a few
people to leave the school or hide
before they start the massacre this is
the end of the manifesto The Notebook
was placed in evidence pictures of every
single page were taken and are attached
to the case after re reviewing the book
spoke with principal Dara who informed
me that while speaking with this person
about the manifesto theusa learned that
blank had begun writing this Manifesto
approximately 9 days ago principal DHA
also advised this person and redacted
was in the building and ready to speak
with me about the matter I contacted
Lieutenant booze and informed him of the
school threat that I was investigating
it was determined chipa County
investigator plutz would assist me due
to the in due to the infinite campus
records showing that redacted lived in
Chipawa County and not the city of
Chipawa Falls short time later Deputy
plutz arrived and I briefed him on what
I had so far we went to the front
conference room and met with principal
Daria blank and Jenny to discuss the
investigation so really quickly really
quickly uh we'll get to this in just a
second we've got about one more page to
go I want you to remember that
additional officers were called to the
campus I want you to remember that when
we talk about some of the previous
incidents where parents were notified
yes and the justification that was used
for that notification remember it's not
just this resource officer it's it looks
like at least two other officers were
called to the campus so an increased
police presence yeah spoiler alert this
is exactly a situation of rules and
standards not being applied equally
which begs the question why parents were
warned about other far less credible in
incidents did not involve multiple
officers and by the way multiple
counties just to be clear they were
notified for far less why not this
one the suspicion would be for the same
reason that we have the manifestos from
the Christ Church shooting we know
everything we could possibly know about
Dylan roof and it required some people
here to get the Nashville Manifesto I
would say it's a similar situation
that's the conclusion to which I would
come most likely in the absence of the
information that everyone should
have I began by stating in the interview
that what I read was very disturbing
Jenna advised she had uh reviewed some
of the pictures that the school
administration at center of the book and
this person stated that it was just
their way of venting they continued
talking about some of the uh School home
issues they were experiencing I informed
Jenna of the same rights I had informed
redacted prior to interviewing them I
again informed them that they were free
to to leave at any point in time they
did not have to answer any questions
that we ask and the door was shut for
privacy I asked if they had any
questions in regards to that they stated
no and we F continuing with the
investigation principal derish explained
his points of view on the manifesto
Jenna then began to talk with redacted
about the manifesto this person stuck to
their word that they were just writing
it down because they were angry and they
were just thoughts and that they were
not a violent person I asked if they had
talked to anyone about this they stated
that they had and that it was uh to a
mental health program called Trevor
which is geared towards the lgbtq
community Target kill Christians jocks
pretty girls the only person I've spoken
with is a an lgbtq based mental health
yeah Consulting program must be a Common
Thread wonder if there's more
information like that in the lists be
helpful they confirmed that they spoke
with this Trevor system on several
occasion and their
plans I asked this person what steps
they had taken in starting the planning
they stated
none but you spoke with Trevor the
lgbtq centered Counseling Service about
your
plans and oh no no I don't have any
plans this is not the fault of this
individual of this child it's the fault
of a system that has failed
them including what you're reading in
this report
which was never sent to you not even I
mean you get Amber Alerts over custody
battles yeah all
right Jenna interrupted and informed me
that blank just this morning had asked
her about making a smoke
bomb she confirmed she just wrote that
off as something odd that a student or a
person would say while in and of itself
that may be true however blank mentioned
a
few really giving the benefit of the
doubt on a lot of this a lot of that
stuff mentioned a few times in the
Manifest that they were looking to make
a smoke
bomb arguably the least concerning of
the bombs included yes I asked them to
explain their reference in the manifesto
about creating smoke bombs and using
them on October
30th they stated that it would be dumb
fun and knew that they wouldn't actually
be able to do this just because of
illogical aspect of getting around the
town to light the bombs they also cited
that the smoke bomb would take a
professional sorry would take
professional grade materials to make and
that they would be unable to complete
this Jenna then asked this person why
they would be looking these things up if
they weren't plan planning on doing this
redacted stated that they were proof
checking the Anarchist Cookbook that
they were reading
yeah so this is very clearly you know
you have children they lie they lie
you've caught them in multiple lies and
what's most disturbing is you've caught
them lying about dates about what
they're doing what they're assembling
why they are reading what they're proof
reading does that
work no that work with anyone I guess it
works with the principal here I guess it
works with the administrative officials
here I guess it's enough for the the
police involved I would argue based on
what we're going to tell you in just a
minute about the actions that they took
it didn't work on them it didn't work on
the police no they knew it it's the
administration's job to inform the
parents right and again I'll show you
where they did formed the parents now in
those situations it wasn't someone
targeting Christians and jock who um for
some reason was discussing this with an
lgbtq plus Centric counselor no no that
wasn't necessarily the case with these
other scenarios but parents were warned
with great haste why not here why not
Nashville proof reading the book like
he's public the publisher well you going
to send it back with a red pen yeah you
got to edit this is way to take this out
oh thermite yeah can't believe I lost
that one
eventually I got around to asking if
there were any firearms in the residence
Jenna informed me a lot of redacted
there is no access to firearms in her
house she informed me at her husband's
house redacted there are several weapons
that are always locked up and the
children do not know the passcode she
also informed me redacted have several
firearms that are not locked up repeat
that they have several firearms that are
not secured did you see the woman that
just got sentenced
to 15 years or just got found guilty not
sentenced one of the reasons was four
counts of 15 years four counts of 15
years not having the Firearms locked up
yeah at the very least we talk about
this this could also be a story
regarding political
prosecution the right people can go
after you for just this oh you don't
have firearms locked up you go to prison
for life oh wait hold on a second we
have someone who is in the direct orbit
of someone who has uh downloaded
purchased tried to procure a physical
copy of the Anarchist Cookbook stated
dates times purchase materials to
assemble weapons and has written down
their plans to use this on fellow
classmates particular fellow classmates
what motivates them so they have a few
unlocked
Firearms they could just as easily right
now be prosecuted just because it
happens why not know about
this a plan was made to go to redacted
to search this person's room for items
related to the manifesto prior to this I
had spoken to Jenna privately and she
stated that she was on board for
allowing me into her home to search the
residents for those items Deputy plutz
offic officer thoron and I arrived at
the address to search the residence
officer thoron remained outside and
spoke with this person outside the
residence while deputy plutz and I
searched the residents while searching
the residents we did not locate anything
of law enforcement interest minus
redacted Amazon account Jenna informed
us that this person does have their own
Amazon account and gets an allowance to
purchase things off of there Deputy
plutz was able to locate a saved items
list while scrolling through the list we
located several items of police interest
including potassium nitride which they
reference in the manifesto to making the
sticky substance the Napal a tidex
bodysuit black trench coat bunson burner
and his R rubber respirator mask uh mask
protection we also located in uh their
notes folder they talked again about
making Napal they cite mixing equal
parts of gasoline and frozen orange
juice pictures of these items were taken
and added to the
case just a quick note uh We've redacted
this information online but there are
some names coming up in these next
paragraphs don't read the names the
police did not redact some of the names
okay did you say frozen orange juice
yes this is another plot by Big Orange
Julius exactly Bird's eyes
involed after searching the residents I
spoke with Jenna about going to redacted
she stated that this person was okay
with law enforcement responding over
there a short time later we arrived at
the residence prior to entering I spoke
with redacted and asked if it was okay
if I could come into the residence and
they stated it
was in redacted room the only thing of
law enforcement interest I located was a
book titled enemies pictures of the
contents of this book were taken were
added to the case at the conclusion of
the search in this room I informed both
redacted and Jenna to look through the
rest of their house for any other
possible Manifesto related items and
keep me post if they found anything
bunch of redacted information here I
terminated contact with Jenna at this
time
so what we have
here is well sorry an event where at no
time were any of the students at risk or
in har arms away thanks to the dedicated
efforts of the Middle School staff seems
like there were great efforts taken by
the police
department this is this is not uh this
is not a half-hearted
investigation and it seems like they
found quite a bit I mean typically
speaking if you're going to look at
someone if they're an adult okay and say
okay is this a legitimate threat do we
have motive it's all over it's all over
here right it's all over this Manifesto
okay do we have specific actions okay do
we have evidence
of materials or plots to pull out set
actions you have a time
frame you have you have saved lists on
Amazon and you have some of those items
hanging
around and do we also have inconsistent
stories that would lead us to Greater
suspicion you have this person lying to
you in this interview all of this is
cause for
concern all of it just to be clear no
one was ever in danger yeah they didn't
believe it I would argue at this point
the school has acted responsibly so far
at that point in time involving the
police trying to figure out what's going
on trying to figure out if this is a
real threat or not trying to figure out
what the next steps are all of that so
everything's on
track and then so far Stonewall yeah so
all this
happens okay
quietly expel this person wait why you
nothing about this
treny now they say that there was no
need for a warning the parents didn't
need to know this doesn't exist in a
vacuum so let's contrast this with the
same school do they do they have a
history of notifying parents of
incidents and are those incidents more
severe than this that would justify not
letting them know okay March 7th 2023
parents were notified by this exact
school when there were false swatting
calls being carried fall school
superintendent Jeff Holmes says they
aren't able to release many details s in
a swatting incident because of the age
of the student they believe responsible
but he says they do take these incidents
seriously chipa Falls Police say the
Dispatch Center received a number of
calls yesterday from what sounded like a
young child one of the calls said there
was an intruder at the high school who
was shooting in the lunchroom the school
resource officer was able to immediately
confirm this information was false
Police Chief Matt kelm says a total of
six 911 calls were made throughout the
course of the day the suspect is a chipa
Falls Elementary School student our law
enforcement officials were able to work
quickly to narrow it down and that we've
actually know who the individual was
that caused the Panic is a good thing
yeah and same school district right so
school this is the the middle school
that we're talking about but same school
district where they would have the same
policy when to notify parents and how to
proceed March
14th so now we have a direct apples you
say that's wding potential school
shooting threat in the district was
reported to parents of 2022 March 14th
2022 that's say 2023 you didn't you just
said March 14th you just felt the need
to add the year I was helping okay thank
you this was the uh following statement
which was sent to parents uh from the
school at 11:30 p.m. this afternoon a
statement was overheard that involves a
potential gun threat at cfms for Tuesday
March 15th this statement was reported
via email at 6:40 p.m. to a teacher the
teacher read the email and fored it to
the CF uh cfms administrative team at
7:25 p.m. we immediately notified the
middle school resource officer and
initiated an
investigation the investigation was
already was completed by 11:05 p.m. and
the threat was deemed not credible now
compare this to a Manifesto to a wish
list to dates and to targets they
notified that in this District
parents of a statement that was
overheard that involves a potential gun
Threat by the way what could that could
that mean someone has unlocked firearms
in the house yeah they can do 15 to life
yeah this is this is a specific Apples
to Apples because this is the middle
school this is the exact middle school
this is the middle school they knew
within a very short period of time that
there was no actual threat here and
still they notified parents of a
Potential Threat so this happened after
school hours it seems like they were
notified of this
thing I don't understand why
notifications went out when you knew
very clearly that there was no actual
threat and that it was not something
that you needed to take seriously not
that you actually found the person
responsible and that you were dealing
with the person in this case but that
the threat did not even exist in the
first place and you notified parents
that same evening immediately jump to it
I think that's actually the right thing
to do potentially very good job why is
it different here and why is your answer
that in that situation you said because
of the swatting thing a couple of
additional officers were seen and you
wanted to explain it they didn't come
rolling up with Sirens blaring and
lights and SWAT teams jumping out of the
back and h h h h h running into the
building that didn't happen is that how
SWAT team sound I don't know that's what
I I hear in movies it's pretty good they
didn't do that so what's
different I'll tell you what's different
this is just my opinion having seen
enough of this and by the way we only
bring you what it is that we can
irrefutably 100% verifiably proof okay
but we have to look at this underworld
very often my opinion it's for the same
reason that we didn't know about the
Nashville Manifesto shooting it's for
the same reason that they don't want to
tell you about registered sex offenders
at drag queen Story Hour it's for the
same they don't want to tell you about
this this uh Biden uh Lackey who's
stealing everybody's luggage if you are
the right marginalized class or if they
see you as an ally then they will treat
you differently it is about rules for
thee and not for me it's the same reason
they want you to believe that white
supremacy is the greatest national
security threat that we have and want to
ignore the unbelievably High the
unprecedented High rates of violence
among the lgbtq plus Community it's not
even close CL it's the same reason that
they want to tell you about stop Asian
hate and not tell you that over 80% of
all physical physically violent crimes
in the Bay Area when they conducted a
pilot study were committed from Black
Americans against asian-americans all
physically violent crimes in the Bay
Area it really it comes down to is the
per the right color or is the per of the
right ideology or marginalized group and
what about the target is this a story
that we can run is this catnip for CNN
ABC NBC CBS it's the same reason that
the hunter Biden laptop they didn't want
to vet it instead they altered the
course of history with your election by
punting it it's the exact same reason
only in this case and I don't ever want
to hear again ever if it saves one life
really really they'll say that if you
want to own a handgun to protect your
house oh gun if it saves one life
okay glad you did glad the cops stepped
in
Nashville if it's and what we don't know
is how long these people may have been
on someone's radar we don't know the
list of targets we don't know the list
of people who this person was enlisting
perhaps motivating perhaps galvanizing
no other parents knew the questions to
ask of their children we'll never know
so wanting to understand the school's
decision
making or the lack of ability thereof uh
a journalist here from M undercover
reached out to the dean of students at
the The chipa Falls Middle School Corey
H let me before I play this for you and
it's uh it's how long is it a 7 minutes
it's a 7 minute call I want to play it
in its entirety look I get it it's not
it's not always the most entertaining
thing when you have to play but if we
don't play the seven minutes the story
would be about you cut 30 seconds out
remember that happened with black rock
yep it's like okay so just because at
this point we don't want to have to
follow up on the lies all of it is out
in the open that's why it's seven
minutes let me provide some context here
they're going to try and make some
claims in this call okay here's a claim
that you'll hear because I don't want to
pause the video that there is no
imminent threat by the student in this
case so there's no need to notify the
parents the truth is that the dean of
students Cory Han themselves informed
police that this was a very serious
matter to be taken seriously and the
student was suspended immediately and
then expelled December 6th in a closed
door session yeah there was nothing to
worry about though immediately removed
this person from the school and in a
closed door session immediately or as
quickly as we possibly could expelled
this student from our school district
yes and you're going to hear another
claim on this call um that uh unlike
this case you know parents were informed
of these other these these previous
incidents because those incidents had a
police presence at the
school there was at least one police
officer who showed up at the school in
addition to the school safety officer
with this very scenario so I just set
that up because you'll listen to the
7-minute call and you may not know how
to call balls and Strikes you can if you
go check out the references you'll know
it's a lie but I just told you here is
the call from our journalist to uh I
want to make sure I get the name
right Dean Corey
Han hello this is Corey uh hey Corey
what's up man it's Mike I left you a
message early how you doing yeah I'm
good I'm good how are you I'm good man I
appreciate you getting back to me I know
you're busy um I just had an issue with
my son that I just wanted to discuss
with you if you just have a
minute yeah yeah absolutely yeah so
unfortunately um uh me and my wife got
divorced a little while back and uh she
has full custody of course so I don't
always hear everything that kind of
happen so I just wanted to one of my
friends is uh on the local police
department there um he had mentioned
there was a a child who was kind of
planning something back in October with
a Manifesto and stuff like that so I I
didn't hear about it so I didn't know if
you guys had alert it my wife and she
didn't tell me um CU that's just kind of
concerning for me if that's the case
again if you guys didn't uh reach out to
parents and let them know for some
specific reason I understand that but I
just wanted to make sure if that event
happened the way it was explained to me
from the police officer that you guys
didn't send an alert out and basically
my wife didn't tell me about it right so
okay yeah yeah so I mean what what I can
tell you is that like there was um there
there was an incident that involved the
student um and I I won't get into kind
of the specifics of that um but there
was there wasn't an incident that would
involve the student and you know we we
found out about it right away and we we
took the actions that we do with with
every student right we investigated it
all the way through um you know brought
we're lucky enough to have a school
resource officer here with us and we we
brought him in on it too and and you
know and we we kind of followed the the
procedures that we normally do with
those things um I I can look back but I
don't believe we sent anything out to
parents um because you know through our
investigation of everything that was
going on there was there was at no time
that we felt um an imminent threat to
any of the kids in our building or our
building at all anything like that um so
that's that's why we we wouldn't have
sent anything out to parents at the time
okay and part of the reason I was asking
because I know there was some swatting
calls and there was an incident like a
year or two ago too where uh an incident
happened it was investigated it was not
credible at the time so you guys did let
parents know at that time so I just
wasn't sure if it was a situation like
that or if it was something more serious
you know yeah yep absolutely and this
was back in October is that
correct uh yeah I believe so I don't
know I can't remember the exact date
okay yeah again I'm not trying to put
anybody on the spot or get anybody in
trouble or anything and one of my
friends from the police department was
telling me that there was a Manifesto
found and it was it was pretty graphic
and stuff so it seemed like something we
would normally or you guys would
normally kind of let parents know about
so I just wanted to you know kind of
clarify that or or clear that up
basically Goa yeah yeah Mike can I can I
ask your last name uh honestly I just
want to remain anonymous right now I
don't want any again I'm not trying to
put anybody on the spot or have my kid
you know uh you know shine a light on
him in any way the main thing I was just
trying to find out is basically if you
let parents know and if my wife didn't
tell me you know so okay yeah I just the
reason I ask is just cuz like I mean
right as as a school district we we
always do everything we possibly can I
mean safety is our number one concern
right there's there's there's never
anything that we do that safety isn't
the Forefront of of what we're doing and
keeping our kids safe keeping our staff
safe everything like that too or
whatever and so um I'm just like just a
little bit curious too that like the the
police department would be would be
leaking something like that to somebody
as well too because right like we work
really closely with them and we just
want to make sure that we're you know
we're all on the same page with kind of
you know who's who's saying what to who
and and and that type of stuff no and I
I definitely get that again this was a
private conversation I don't want to put
him in any hot spot or anything like I
said to the way he had described it uh
it just seemed a little more serious um
than some of the other stuff that you
let parents know about
right okay yeah and and like I said like
we you know we we do our due diligence
every time and and at no point did we
feel like there was an imminent threat
to anybody um or any any safety concern
like that in our in our building at the
time or anything which is which is why
we didn't reach out to to parents can I
just ask why you would let parents know
about the other stuff the swatting calls
the the other incidents that were deem
not credible but you wouldn't let
parents know about this I'm just just
curious what's the
difference yeah well I mean so Mike I'm
going to be totally honest with you like
it I'm I'm a little bit concerned about
this conversation because it seems like
you're you're digging for some things
like I'm just I'm that I'm just yeah no
I'm digging I'm digging for I'm digging
for that exact question I just asked
right I know we let parents know about
stuff that had happened that was less
credible this seemed a little more
credible to me so it just seemed like
something we would normally let parents
know about right okay yeah and I and I
guess like you know if you if you would
like to come in too and discuss this in
person I I would love to do that too and
um you know we can kind of go through
all that we can bring officer Downey
into the conversation as well and um and
he can kind of fill you in on on some of
those different types of things so yeah
no I would definitely possibly be
interested in that for sure um but again
just a simple question like why would
you let parents know about less credible
things when you had something that was
seems more credible to me based on the
conversation I have and you wouldn't let
parents know about that I'm just just
honestly that's my main
question okay yeah and and I I
understand that right and and I I get
your your your your conversation that it
seems more credible um you know I would
say with with the swatting instance and
things like that like you know there
were um sometimes police officers that
showed up to our building and so forth
and so um you know obviously we we let
people know that there was not there was
not anything going on everybody was safe
everybody was okay in this situation we
you know we we got to it right away we
handled it really quickly and um and
again we we felt that was no credible
threat to you know to our our staff or
our student at the time or anything like
that so but but that's my question like
previously there was no we didn't think
there was a threat we didn't think there
was any problems and we let parents know
but what's the difference between this
situation well but but again I I mean
those those previous ones right like
there was if police were there or police
showed up um at our building right
people people see that and so we we let
them know that but this one again we
offic didn't an officer come to the
building for this one
now well we have a school resource
officer at our building every single day
but wasn't there we we employ we employ
school resource officer Dan Downey okay
so Dan Downey is is directly through the
local department and he basically just
just handles it as what you're saying
well yeah so he's our school resource
officer and the high school the high
school the school resource officer Brian
flug and so both both schools has a have
a full-time school resource officer okay
all right so you're just saying the
difference is cops came there was more
of a scene so you want to let people
know with this one there wasn't that
same scene so you just didn't feel
necessary to basically just scare people
I guess or alert you know something like
that
sure
okay all right well again that was my
main thing I wanted to know if there was
something that came out that I just
wasn't made aware of so if that's the
case um I might take you up on an
inperson meeting at some point so we can
discuss but for now I think that kind of
satisfies my question all right well
thank you so much for calling and have a
great weekend cool thanks man I
appreciate you com back to me bye yeah
bye couple of things first off I just
hurt my see have a cut on my knuckle and
put on hand sanitizer that's terrible
man so hit the smash the rumble button
or whatever to hit like just to give me
a second question do you think when he
said have a good weekend he meant that
it's a good point I I question the
sincerity and you know what that's also
it's not the worst thing the worst thing
is the potential murder right let's be
clear about that but the arrogance yes
uh yeah
who are you I'm a public servant you're
a concern what you're a concerned parent
what are you a j you think people have
the right to know I'll determine when
people have the right to know oh wait
hold a second is that a stage if it
saves one more
life why won't you take a stand for gun
against gun
violence and that that's a terrible
that's a terrible like bar if there is
the appearance of danger will notify
parents if it's possible that somebody
might call you and say hey he guess what
I saw I live across from the school
there were two police cars there did
your son or daughter say anything about
that today and then a parent calls Up So
to avoid that yeah they don't notify
parents when there's an actual threat as
opposed to the previous warning that
they sent to the parents when a teacher
willing to bet that you can probably
guess the political persuasion and
likely gender of the teacher who said I
overheard someone make a make a
statement about a gun threat these are
the same people who call the cops on
neighbors because they find out that the
neighbor is a responsible gun owner that
everybody Panic here there's no
appearance of it and nobody knows rules
for thee and not for me it's the same
reason that dases duza is the only
person yeah to have to wear an ankle
bracelet for giving too much to a
political campaign of his friend who who
lost you don't live in a
country of Law and Order if laws are not
applied equally if one person can be
prosecuted and get 15 to life for having
an unlocked firearm and someone else who
has a someone else can be completely
unaccountable when they are in charge of
the safety of students or a district and
they have a plan materials motive
timeline and
Targets on the other hand you had an
unlocked gun you'll never see the light
of day so what happened here the school
and let me be really clear our source
and and I'm so grateful to you everyone
out there mug Club none of this we are
funded by viewers like you if you're a
first-time viewer we have been
demonetized for years on YouTube notice
there are very few sponsorships on this
show because we answer to you without
you without mug Club none of this
happens 89 annually of course you get
this show Nicks you get the Friday you
get twice the show we're going to take
your chat regarding this story on mug
Club you get Alex Jones we're growing
every day but none of this happens
without you and the reason we are able
to discuss these stories and break
them okay YouTube strike
it fine that's because of you just to be
clear and you tend to be good people
because this actually came uh from our
source they were very
adamant in requesting this that we will
do our best to ensure that this young
person is able to get the help that they
desperately need if someone from the
family wants to reach out we are here to
assist discuss help any way we
can and you can send an email to our
secure tip line we will keep it
completely Anonymous just like our
original Source Who tipped us off to
this investigation this was requested by
The Source actually for me to State
verbatim and we agree with it this is
not about a disturbed child just like
I've said there are no trans
six-year-olds trans
children there are no there are children
who are more unhappy one of
them there are children who may be uh
suffering from greater afflictions than
others of course there are no
children who
plot a massacre purchase the materials
necessary read them read them
again fact check them practice and set a
timeline those children don't
exist without bad schooling or parenting
it's not about the child it's about the
parents my child is trans you are a
problem parent your child doesn't have
money can't get puberty blockers this is
you this child got the Anarchist
Cookbook and wants to kill Christians
and jocks and pretty girls and is a fan
of KL marks that's a you problem the
school here buried crucial information
that you the parents absolutely have a
right to
know the entire system failed this child
the school failed them social workers
failed them their family failed
them
and it was all done with an assist
really assisting each
other this child was failed and rather
than taking accountability for failing
this child I'd rather Gaslight
you get their get their Benny's packages
hey if this were me the honor The
Honorable thing here would be to
resign if I were in charge of the safety
of these
children that's what that's what you do
that's your primary job your job is not
to teach them that America is
single-handedly responsible for slavery
while ignoring the African slave trade
and that there are more slaves on earth
now than ever before that's not your job
your job is to make sure they're safe to
learn to read
write and hopefully to learn how to be a
contributing citizen to the Village it
takes a village well guess what the
village isn't
working roll back up to the verbatim
real quick I just want to make sure I
get this exactly correct so at the very
top of it right here so when we say that
we will do our best to ensure this young
person is able to get the help they
desperately need if somebody from the
family wants to reach out we are here to
assist mugclub that's you yep when we
say we will do it that means that mug
Club the resources brought in by mug
Club you will be used right you guys
will be able to help ensure that this
person gets the help that they need if
somebody in the family reaches out to us
and expresses a desire to take us up on
the offer you can help potentially
change the course of somebody's life and
if you are a concerned family member who
has a child a son or a daughter at the
school or in the school district or you
have some information that is concerning
or this raises some alarm bells and um
you either have more information or
would like more information that within
the legal boundaries we can provide we
of course want to be able to help you
you can send in your your contact
information your email and you know we
have a pretty good track record of
keeping our people Anonymous remember
Nashville mhm they let seven people go
on paid leave hired them back never
found they got a free vacation got a
free
vacation remember with Nashville they
tried to say why would you do this and
hurt the families I'm
guarant calling it they'll say doing
this harms our ability to keep to keep
our students safe in the
future okay what they'll never tell you
is
how they always invoke safety yes and
same with the government it's always
those are the things the buzzwords kids
safety that's when you know the you know
they're pulling the wo over your eyes
exactly those Buzz words are always the
same especially when not taking
accountability for their actual job
which is to ensure the safety of their
children well actually teaching is first
in a normal World teaching would be
their objective safety came second but
not anymore you're right yeah unless
unless it's the wrong person yeah then
safety comes nowhere right on the list
these kids don't have to go online to
get radicalized they just go to class
now it's a good point yeah that's a good
point even if you're a parent and you
say hold on a second hold on a second
wait a second you know I I'm your dad
I'm your mom God created man and woman
God created husband and wife and you
know what it's a good thing for people
to be free and you need to learn to be
responsible and you need to learn that
freedoms also come some responsibilities
and Privileges and you need to learn how
to treat your fellow man with respect
you need to learn to treat others the
way you want to be treated but it's okay
to disagree you need to stand up for
what it is that you believe in and these
are the values that we believe and this
is a great country and your grandfather
fought for this country you maybe get a
couple of hours think of this most of
their
time most of their time is spent with
these
people till they go off to college where
we all know it gets better there for
that go see the change my Minds in this
case we thank them very much the team
here I cannot take credit for this great
job you take credit for this because I
don't even know the names of many of the
investigative journalists here I go oh
that's Skullcrusher 42
cool depose me
uh so there's a lot that I don't
even know Nick and I come from the
comedy the entertainment industry world
I can't take credit for it but you can
because you are exactly what funds this
unit here and uh we thank you we ask
that you continue to do so if you are
watching right now Rumble click that
button it's as easy as that you join mug
Club you can start at $9 mugas right now
uh cuz I get it for some of you 89 is a
is a is a tough spend and we ask that uh
you know you consider joining annually
$89 you get it might save a classroom
yes if hey if $89 saves one classroom
yeah and if you're on
YouTube well is it still on YouTube
right now who knows does anyone know is
it still running yeah it's still running
oh well we're on borrowed time soow you
piss off but first thank you mugclub
undercover we're going to go take your
chance on mug
[Music]
[Applause]
Club
yeah